est ce que tu es prête pour faire une
interview première fois première baffe
je n'ai jamais dû gifler enfin pas mes
parents s'entend par les copines sa
charpente mais par les hommes
sympa non un bon jamais à le premier qui
essayent premier noël premier noël
oui j'avais une jaunisse je me souviens
j'avais une très belle robe de chambre
jaune assorties justement hommage à nice
premier objet fétiche un humour ce dont
j'avais arracher les oreilles et les
yeux tu la gardes et j'ai toujours su le
ravec
non c'est pas avec lui que tu dois
premier péché premier péché qu'est ce
que j'ai pu faire une bêtise en effet
hall à l'ag de trop d'enfants tu sais
tiens moi mon premier péché si je peux
pas le raconter à la tv on va visionner
entre nous dans l'été deux petits
copains comme ça on était jeunes qu avec
l âge cet ange a déjà annoncé passage
tu joues à quoi dans le jeu des petites
j'étais chef de bande
tu joues et tu préférais jouer quand il
était petit à cache-cache au docteur à
cache cache jamais joué tellement
docteur fou non même si j'ai chanté
docteur j'étais bien sûr martina far
away première boum
j'avais 19 ans et demi je suis resté dix
minutes pas plus couper les ponts c'est
quoi qui ne plaisait pas les filles et
les garçons soient serrés les uns contre
les autres filières take away j'ai fait
le service militaire dont sa vie savoir
plus à sa première idole c'était quitte
à dorothée à toi c'était fred astaire
ginger rogers et surtout au très bon
premier flirt ou t'en souviens eux c'est
qu'ils en angleterre où il était grand
très grand très grand que s'ils
s'étaient passés exactement qui
ressurgissent
ces gens qui ont souffert quand il veut
être un petit peu plus et surtout la
première cuite
certainement après un spectacle quelques
jours après ce jeu de la vérité chantal
goya sympa ce premier amour
bon je ne fais pas plus cher que je te
parle d'amour quand même des musclés
il convient salle au passé
quelques bars pour monsieur ma fille je
crois que j'ai un bon contact avec la
dame claire manavit sont musclés fais
gaffe et sur cinq sont grands là aussi
il y en a cinq faits mais s'accroît
premier amour alors hausse était très
gentil très très très romantique très
romantique bon première expérience
sexuelle
ça s'est très bien passé merci c'est
vers quel âge à cet art là aussi
d'avant-hier veut battre
l'analyse fait gaffe c'était vers quel
âge où j'avais 18 ans quand même oui et
alors c'était très beau à regarder un
bon souvenir
tu la revue au à ces cas c'est le
mutisme arrivé 1er juin tu as fumé
j'avais jamais fumé de dollars je crois
pas écoute si tu as dit qu'on allait
être sincère ldf bon d'accord premier
succès
côté télé côté 10 côté premier succès de
ta vie la première fois où tu t'es dit
tiens ça y est ça marche
y'a pas d'hier non il n'a pas d'hier n'a
rien rien ne prendre que deux claques
dans la gueule
arrêtée là premier succès je crois que
c'est où la menteuse je crois ou là
vraiment je pendant là dans la rue les
gens m'ont dit à la menteuse et
amoureuse c'est quand les gens dans la
rue te parle et mes petites briques
fabien marché à new york
premiers millions d'anciens francs mais
pas trop longtemps n'est pas très
longtemps
il est dirigé par m il a peur de toi tu
m'attends chez c'est la première fois
que je vois quelqu'un de torche est
bonne fille s'est vite un bravo premier
million de nouveaux faut juste pas à
temps honnêtement j'en sais rien c'est
sûrement content tu sais pas ce qu'on me
dit attention est au rouge bon d'accord
attention tout passe dans la drogue le
premier geste que tu fais le matin je
râle je croyais que c'est une question
piège alors qu'est ce que ce grâce de
l'écologie qu'est ce que tu fais le
matin
c'est pas allumer la tv non cette
deuxième c'est comme mtv chez toi une
dans chaque pièce
ça fait combien entre tu sais qu'on est
le 21 mars et le 1er kouassi le 21 mars
a travaillé 30 ans premier jour du
printemps
eh oui et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu